my name is Ron Meyer I'm publications
editor
and it's my pleasure to welcome you on
behalf of the harriman institute and its
director Kim Martin and the Department
of Slavic language is now shared by
license out I literally stumbled across
today the information that maidenhair
Hill sheesh guns book newest or next to
newest book in English has been
shortlisted by excuse me by 3% for the
prize of best translated book of the
last year so and it's among very lovely
company I'd like to start by just
reading from a review of maidenhair
which was published last year one of you
may recognize this review mihail
shishkin has been publishing in russia
to a claim and accolades for almost 20
years his work is elusive Dunson
strikingly beautiful he's a challenge
for any translator and a pleasure for
the Russian reader and now Marion
Schwartz his translation of his novel
vinieron volus 2006 maidenhair finally
brings the full complexity of shiffman's
work to the english-speaking world
Schwartz's translation faithfully
conveys the structure introduced
intricacies of shishkin stovl providing
no more hints or signposts for the
english-language reader the yellow the
author allows his native readership the
novel is built from a web of textual
sources assembled so seamlessly that the
subtlety of connections can at times
flummox even the conscientious reader
those lines are penned by Bradley or
escape our graduate student the Slavic
department whose largely responsible for
much of organization
Christian's visit i'll keep my rest
remarks very short since the two
speakers are well known in their own
rights Mikhail shishkin has won all
three of Russia's major literary awards
the Russian Booker the national
bestseller and the boss shayateen ego
prize the translation of his novel
maidenhair has already shown up in short
list of best translations his the
translation of his novel the light in
the dark was just published in the UK by
quercus books and this month he is
teaching a seminar on classics and
politics in Russian literature rack at
Columbia Marion Schwartz is past
president of the American literary
translators association and a
prize-winning translator she is a
principal translator the works of
nienaber Bhairava she's known for her
translations of the Russian classics of
loma hero of our time envy as well as
contemporary works by olga slavickova
and andre galassi mode she has received
the barber health translation prize
twice and the axial translation award
among many many other prizes and now
it's my pleasure to turn it over to me
Hal shishkin and interested in marriage
Wars thank you very much thank you
everyone for coming we're going to do a
reading from the book and and then leave
a lot of time for discussion and
questions I wanted to say about this
book it's not the first work by Mikhail
that I've translated I translated a
story that's onwards Without Borders
called the calligraphy lesson which is
one of his earlier works and I've
translated another story that appeared
in a two lines anthology so when I was
asked to translate the book I already
knew that I already knew that we had a
style a really strong stylistic affinity
sometimes I translate authors who are
much further from my own sensible
but I think one of the reasons that the
translations tend to be better or tend
to be good with with shishkin s work is
that I think they're gorgeous and I
think that the interest in language and
in the word pretty much parallel my own
so in translating this book one of the
main issues and it's something you'll
hear in this excerpt is his use of
different levels of diction and
different kinds of writing and you'll
see r a couple of them in this just in
this small passage I I would urge I
don't think this this is a problem with
this particular audience but it's a it's
a book that will kind of throw you
upside down within the first page and
you'll say where is this book going
you'll if you don't you haven't been
told about it before it has no chapters
it has some does have some line breaks
in it but it doesn't it doesn't have any
chapters it ends in a very interesting
way from the point of view of
punctuation but the reward the payoff
particularly once you get to the end
after you've absorbed all these
different stories and these different
voices is tremendous it's the the last
20 pages are nothing if not for to Asik
so I like the book as you can tell and I
don't know we clearly want to say
something thank you very much modern for
such introduction and thank you very
much for coming and if you don't mind I
would read in Russian and modern in
English I hope you like my language as I
do actually it's my enemy I hate Russian
because my whole life I'm just
struggling again I'm fighting it
sometimes I win but most of the time it
wins I'll start with epigraph ypres
budget prison yo budgets khazana vernis
toast OTB empanada read give itto
statistic Ronaldo Yemeni Yaiba slovan
balls osman mir is logan vez krishnam at
Craven Navarro ha Sinan Erie and your
ashes will be called and will be told
return that which does not belong to you
reveal what you have kept to this time
for by the word was the world created
and by the word shall we be resurrected
revelation of baruch Ben Neriah block
not ruchika stockin wadi sonses acronym
vada obstacle a postcard solution is a
check music arts le sole mission is a
shisha periods in a patologia if drug
nagar kirtan binibini esta noite sapa
Hosanna aha ition azzaro Odisha that
provides a deer budget notebook pen
glass of water Sun outside the water in
the glass let's a sunbeam in not just a
little Sunbeam but a big fat one it
spills over the ceiling and suddenly for
a second looks like an ear also an
embryo the door opens they bring the
next one in Lapras a beauty crud
capricci name pocket or on the procedure
a produced a blini oh batricia question
briefly describe the reasons why you are
requesting asylum at yet yaara bata na
domashniy nagrani says kazakhstan um via
napier basel ii narcotic FYE machine
moyna charnock Bulls name is govori my
dog named Billy
Choza krovati Gaza yay for me acaba la
Garza yawn epistle pismo VFS by chilis
nacelle Cagney now let's my adores
Bielema shreena OmniPod vanilla skazal
shto etta pair were predators Dina
answer I used to work in customs on the
Kazakhstan border soldiers would bring
in drugs in their vehicles and my
superior was in cahoots with them we
were supposed to look the other way and
write them up properly I wrote a letter
to the FSB a few days later a truck ran
over my daughter on the street they
called me and said this was my first
warning a pro's appreciate a great
cappuccino pocket or on the procedure a
pedestal any aberration question briefly
describe the reasons why you are
requesting asylum at viet novel burg
gubernatorial activa pedir joel
candidate apposite see oh just well as
meeting of practice des Beaux rockport
machine minnieofoz of olive mill it so
it really pre-credit boo stupid bro
chief rocka wats to oblige the serosa
blotchy enemy nanak Ratna minez be valet
periodistas Chamillionaire a zillion 00
produced a bueno berisha mano aquellos
na medicines Casey di testa Oh Perillo
mitchell st guru ki yaad relief pass
Leslie his beanie yeah cheaper Kaku
avidity invalid enema gora voltage oh my
asian a precocious em noi our exotica
answer i actively supported the
opposition candidate in the
gubernatorial elections and took part in
protest rallies and collected signatures
i was called in to the police and they
demanded that i stopped coming out with
revelations against the provincial
leadership I was beaten up several times
by plainclothes police attached to my
application for asylum I have medical
certificates about my broken jaw and arm
and other consequences of the beatings
now as you see I'm disabled and can't
work my wife who came with me has
I'm a cancer Varro's epizootic rad
cappuccino pocket or on the procedure
produced eleni a bearish question
briefly described the reasons why you
are requesting asylum latvia yah bowlin
speedin oh na siguro dev said mini or
knowledge decision idha jimenez
resilience Albanese prepare 11 across
Omaha cheaper nicho union near a boat
need Rosie natoma nice corner at the
irish all talk yes if serrano but the
hut the codes DSU was a HS Kehoe slavia
with nikki knit answer I have AIDS
everyone in town shunned me even my wife
and children I got infected when I was
in the hospital during a blood
transfusion I have nothing now no job no
friends no home I'm going to die soon
this is what I decided if I'm going to
croak anyway why not do it here with you
inhumane conditions after all you're not
going to kick me out what pros I be sure
to grad cappuccino pocket or on word
processor a pedestal a neo berisha
question briefly describe the reasons
why you're requesting asylum at viet
blue moon chance k prob aslam is Amelia
vivo de by aiming a Dracula there was a
voice vote by the name of Dracula in the
Orthodox land of Wallachia at nas de tu
es que pasa press laulima pot Slav
Strabo venom at Casa de otra vez la
nevera epica it's mo one day the Turkish
Pasha sent invoice to him and they
demanded that he reject his Orthodox
faith and submit to them Bosley Guevara
slave OD national Israel Shoppach anova
pros pooch ammonia's karthik mo bros n
villa cavaco sadara at vocelli taco
avicii go sued our Zilla nasha image
it while speaking with the voivode the
invoice failed to remove their hats and
when asked why they were insulting the
great sovereign in this way they replied
such as the custom of our land sovereign
todrick ola galal am soo gyum guardia me
ribbit rabba Kega la vampa slow yetta's
lawl if caleb ratna velev paradox pashto
bonus aegean abuchi rosna then Dracula
ordered his servants to nail the caps to
the invoice heads and sent their bodies
back ordering that the Pasha be told
that God is one but customs very Arizona
Pasha prishel prabhas la newseum losa
grown the army he still gravity we watch
the enraged Pasha came to the Orthodox
land with an enormous army and began
plundering and killing voivode Rikuo
Sabra yo soy yo me amna gotchas Dana
voice co in Apollo musalmano g 00 Billy
who knows esto ya Brazil big stone the
voivode dracula assembled his entire
modest host and attacked the muslims one
night killed many of them and put them
to flight ultram honest Royals motors
lame estas himself with white bite some
in the morning he organized the review
of his surviving soldiers keturah gamble
spirit tamo chest villa jovis devil in
AZ value of each ism anyone wounded in
the front had great honor bestowed upon
him and the title of Knight acabo de
Rana balanus Pina davao villa else's
ethnical Guevara dynamos no Donna anyone
wounded in the back was ordered impaled
as he said you are a wife not a husband
Oh Lucifer Burton para yo la status via
voice cover Aetna miss me abortion
ibadat Nyota joomla learning this the
Pasha pulled the remnants of his army
back not daring anymore to attack this
land doc Jill we would add Rockville of
a halogen induction
I below stop or oman John's case Amelia
no Ganesha OH bogey beneath in yamashina
so the voivode dracula went on to live
on his possessions and at that time
there were many poor destitute sick and
feeble people in the wool akhiyan land
Vito's tolko yo is Amelia mooch its
initials knowledge a villain syempre
chick Nemo seeing how many unfortunate
people were suffering in his land he
ordered them all to come see him yes
abrazos viciously am nauseous Tony
Hsieh's nuh Callie a case I wrote charak
neva villa camille st s taliani moge
average cash days o Ignacio bolillo
katoa pottery Nina gear to ejection
glossy photo above emerged from Cena
Tony private Nam sudhir a between
e-brochure non-thermal braccia a
multitude without number unfortunates
cripples and orphans hoping for great
mercy from him gathered and they each
began telling him of their misfortunes
and pains one about a lost leg another
about an eye poked out one about a dead
son another about an unfair trial and an
innocent brother thrown in prison he
will pledge village east own style
possum on Jan schism Leah great was a
lamentation and a whale hung over the
entire wall akhiyan land tagged up a
villa Dracula subrata see oh god no
villa Ko Grammy no lettuce lucha Castro
no evil elder Tim Yost mrs. Khanna EP
Giada volna then Dracula ordered them
all assembled in a single edifice built
for the occasion and ordered that they
be given fine chemicals and plenty of
drink an Israeli dealer it was vasilis
they ate drank and made merry untuk
depression him is Brazil choice show
with her teacher then he came to them
and asked what else do you want an easy
at each other tovia dead boy
Getty Villa kikusui dari Pashto piece
nami tak kak tebya Bourassa mid they all
replied only God knows and you great
sovereign do with us as God instructs
talents column hi GT s de lo vas be
special nominations VA esta buena como
vez NOS denebola stubble Niblick le voy
a pedir Anina gear eviction glossy a
bummer from xenia in a private Nam
Sudhir then he told them do you want me
to make you without sorrow in this world
so that you want for nothing so that you
do not be mon your lost leg or poked out
I your dead son or unfair trial I knees
reach a lenovo over to chill de
Arte de Lucia kocham go so dirty they
were hoping for some miracle from him
and they all answered we do sovereign
Doug Don Julio superior taormino abney
ste salami y padre e Blue Lagoon veliki
if she of Nam gorilla then he ordered
the building locked surrounded with
straw and set on fire and the fire was
great and all in it burned spasiba
questions comments and you're welcome I
know us
hello here's a microphone thank you so
much for coming to read for us I'm Susan
burnofsky I wanted to meet you anyway
but I wanted to ask you would you say
something about it you know Ron and
introducing the whole evening said
something about are you I forget now
said something about documentary
materials incorporated into the novel or
just inspiration can you talk a little
bit about the genesis of the book you
sure actually this book had two
beginnings the first beginning was when
I came to Switzerland and it was
actually no immigration in the sense of
the 20th century it was just family
matter and I was looking for a job and
it was impossible to find a job because
I didn't know anything yeah I was just
Russian writer nobody wants to pay money
just for being Russian writer and so I
was happy to find this job as an
interpreter for the police for the
immigration office and it is very bad
job it's well-paid but it's very bad job
you understand me maybe if you made the
same job because you see after coming in
the evening after coming home having
dinner with the family you want to relax
you want to say some funny things which
happened to you during your day and you
can't you can't relax because funny
stories were not told they're just
horrible stories and actually when
coming to Switzerland my first idea was
as a Russian writer I'm lost what should
I write about in this dull boring
country because Russian writer needs
Russian stories Russian pressure you're
the atmospheric pressure in Russia is
absolutely different
and through my job I came to the middle
point of Russian pressure in Switzerland
so I came to Switzerland and plunged
into Russia and Russian stories and it
was actually the beginning of the novel
it was clear the only possibility for me
to to survive what was to write about
this actually it was not a job for
normal people you are normal people
can't work there they they leave or they
stay but they became robbers just
nothing personal they don't listen to
the stories just thinking of football
just writing down the stories sending
them to burn to the federal immigration
office and was interesting that I lost
this job actually after publishing the
novel the null was published in Russia
and at once I didn't get any
possibilities for making money as
interpreter because I can understand
this which official office would like to
have a writer as an interpreter nobody
wants so nothing personal just just I
lost my job after that I couldn't fight
any other job as an interpreter so after
2005-2006 I have I must leave only or
with with my books yeah and sometimes it
was very bad sometimes I got some
fellowship or some prize and yeah and
actually it was the first beginning it
was the second beginning of the novel
and the first beginning was many years
ago
when my mother gave me to read her
Diaries which was young Diaries and you
know that maybe a third so a big part of
the novel are the Diaries and the
memoirs of Isabella river and that
surely it started with these Diaries of
my mom she was very ill with cancer and
before dying she gave me this to read
and I read this and I couldn't believe I
couldn't believe my eyes it was written
in late forties early fifties it was the
most dark time of Russian history the
horrible time yeah everyone was afraid
you know there were horrible time for
Jews for all people in Russia
concentration camps rest and so on and
there was nothing of the kind of this in
these Diaries this where there is
written by a happy girl she was happy
because it is raining outside she was
happy because it snowing outside she was
happy because she's reading good books
she's happy because she has good friends
she's longing for great love she's
listening to her heart is the great love
coming or not yet yeah she's true that
the great love is waiting for her in
this life otherwise it's impossible to
imagine the life at all I couldn't
understand how could she be so blind so
naive and then after cordetta leaving
for Switzerland I left all the family
our cars with my brother and he kept it
at his summer house near Moscow
and it burned and everything disappeared
everything and at once I realized that I
was blind I was a naive I was absolutely
foolish because it was not the blindness
of this young girl yeah looking for love
it was the wisdom of somebody who sent
that girl on this earth in our human
darkness to enlighten this darkness with
her striving for love as a candle and
the somebody had always sent these girls
on the world with this task and will
always send because this is this
enlighten with it like a candle is the
only way to fight the human darkness the
violence the cruelty and so for me it
was at once clear it's my next novel but
I couldn't write about my mom so I wrote
about Isabella yerevan and she was a
real person she was singer Roman singer
so not opera singer but Roman singer and
she was favorite singer by my father I
remember always he him listening to two
old disks and she was born 1899 and she
died 2002 she spent in Russia this whole
horrible 20th century and after her
death she didn't leave anything so no
there is no memories nothing because
people
who lived in 30s 40s 50s they were
afraid of their past you would never
know what tomorrow will be dangerous
what happened what had happened in your
past so they just wanted to get rid of
their past so and after her death there
was no no biography actually nothing
yeah it was not possible to come to know
where was she during the Civil War was
she with the white so what should be the
red and for me it was clear i will give
her her life back because for me she was
a metaphor she was a symbol of a girl
just striving for love singing about
love and that that was her fight that
was her struggle against the time
against this horrible time against the
whole situation she was singing about
love for slaves so my parents my
grandparents they were slaves and for
them it was very important to listen to
her voice because listening to her
singing yeah it gave them much more to
survive that than food with her voice
with her singing gave these slaves the
their dignity their human dignity and so
I wrote her memoirs about her childhood
in rostov before the First World War I
wrote her Diaries during her first world
war Civil War 20s 30s I tried not
nothing to invent so if I had the
possibility to describe truly for
example her
school she attended here if I could find
some memoirs about this place where she
was if I could find the real names of
all the teachers so firm it was
important it was very important for this
resurrection but sure I had to invent
something and it's a question it's a
moral question do I have the right to
invent something for a real existing
person or not and one day I wake I woke
up in panic because I realized one day
we will so one night I woke up and I
realized that one day we will meet we
will meet she and me and I imagine this
situation very clearly I will come up to
her and say Isabel Daniel own prestige
amenia it is job Thomas Thomas lublu so
i will say is about Daniel excuse me I
did it why why I love you because I love
you and she would answer Raja Mishra
show spasiba it's all right Nisshin
thank you thank you so and after that
there was no more question for me
anymore right thing about urine and
giving her her her life back hmm so that
was a little bit about how I how I came
to this novel
question for Marion about translating
the novel from just little bits that
we've seen this there's a lot of well I
imagine the hardest parts are not the
unusual vocabulary but it's catching the
style and how can you give any budding
translators a couple secrets into your
your arsenal of how you attack attacks
this complex in fact actually the
vocabulary was really hard this was
extremely there's a lot going on in the
book that you do not have to know all of
it to read it but you do have to know
all of it to translate it and I was and
in fact this book would not have been
possible without me kyle's help to know
everything that was going on tremendous
amount for those of you who are
translators I know there's some here he
created an incredible document for me
with because the English translation was
one of the last or a later one there had
been many others he compiled a 40 page
document with all the questions from all
the translators and his answers in page
order yeah wouldn't you like to have
that and still of course I had questions
some of the questions didn't relate to
me like in Norwegian apparently when you
say upstairs you have to know if you're
on the second or third floor this was
not an issue for me but there were a lot
of issues with some sometimes the issue
the factual issues the vocabulary issues
gave me information about what the style
should be when I was reading the book i
came across the word a really surprising
word nigga chill knock a word I've never
seen in Russian before but of course I
understood it
and it means Negro child except it's in
it's a word with an ending that
indicates offspring but usually is for
animals I thought oh my goodness so I'm
going to have to use nigger I just had
this horrible feeling and I'm thinking
well if I have to I have to write and
and then he started talking about Asha
dalka and I'm thinking why is there she
Tolkien this she talked as a counting
rhyme well it turned out that he was
referring to what we now will is
actually referring to a book that we now
know is and then there were none which
was originally called Ten Little Indians
and the original counting rhyme in
English was ten little niggers to my
great relief I don't think anybody
remembers that it was well maybe some
people here but most people don't know
that it was ten little niggers ten
little indians is far enough back that
we can go to Indian and leave the
niggers behind in this particular case
so in fact he was there you're as to
your question Susan about the different
what what ron was hinting at there are
he does use all kinds of texts the first
paragraph of the book is from the
Persian Wars it's the history of the
Persian Wars and then there's English
readers will see things from classic
mysteries obviously Agatha Christie but
there are others and people in other
languages will or people Russians will
certainly see other other texts kind of
poke up that are cannot be evoke tin
English one of the questions was this is
a quote from Chekov right and he said
don't laugh he said yes just use the
canonical Chekov translation for this
and everyone will get it
this is not available to me this is not
available to me so if you know Chekov
you may catch the reference anyway but
reading the book you don't have to catch
all those things as he says there's an
ideal reader who he knows by looking
into the mirror and I think the
overwhelming just fascination of the
book and the beauty of it keeps you
going so although you will not catch
everything I someone said to me well
could you annotate it and I thought you
know that would be like three times the
length of the book if you annotated it I
thought you know there's going to be a
lot of dissertations written about this
book and and that will be the annotation
so as far as advice to translators my
standard advice is to well certainly to
read all kinds of things in in Russian
you have to know what standard Russian
is you have to know how tales sound you
have to know how how bureaucratic
language sounds and if you can't
identify those things you can't
reproduce them I don't think the problem
is reproducing them I think the problem
is identifying them and a great many
translations suffer because in my
opinion because translators are so
enamored of the source language that
they just want to revel in its
bizarreness and and don't end up using
the language of the translation in a
meaningful way taking a translator can
help the reader you have to understand
many things by writing comments why
don't you like to write comments you
mean in the book yeah in the book when i
read translated book and i see the
comments by the translator i love it
it's much more interesting
than the text itself yeah yeah my
husband said the same thing um I think
in this book there would be so many
comments that you would not you would
lose the book it would just overwhelm it
no I know some sorry footnote you mean
footnotes yes yeah footnotes or
commences at the end of the book I know
some translations maidenhair made for
example in Norwegian language and there
are a lot of comments I love it it's
this is the first time I've heard it's
not the custom in in America for a
literary translation to have have notes
I i do like translators introductions
and I have written those for other books
that that fill in some of that
information I don't think that that but
that's usually for classics i would say
that has not died now i will never
forget i will never forget it's a
apropos translating my Bulgarian
translator actually I always get
questions from the translator per email
and I love it it means that the
translator is really working hard on the
book if he and I didn't get any
questions from my Bulgarian translator
and I write males to my Bulgarian
publisher give er give er ease of gurgi
why no questions and he answered I asked
even the Taman off and he answered
everything is clear and his everything
is clear to the translator it so it's
something is wrong yeah and then the
book appeared in Bulgarian language in
Sofia I was invited to Sofia to the book
presentation
and I heard from different people who
know Russian and Bulgarians well it's
brilliant translations brilliant
translation okay after the book
presentation we are sitting in a
restaurant event come on us or realism
and with such a beard and he speaks
Russian better than I do he is better in
Russian literature than I do with an
iron and after having some what cuz i
asked him even now tell me please why
didn't you ask any question and he
answered and what if i had to translate
homer and i realized for a translator
ever dead writer is the best writer i
actually so sorry to interrupt you I
used to think that too but I was just
young now I appreciate it I must I must
say that one of the points when this
came in very handy this this opus of
answers was towards the end all of a
sudden I mean I had no idea what these
sentences meant or why they were there
it was very lovely but how they all fit
together was not immediately clear to me
and I was and I looked and I think it
was I don't think I had to ask you i
think it was in the in the compendium or
i may have asked you and I said what's
happening here worried and he said oh
those are palindromes which there was a
whole section that was full of
palindromes which I had didn't notice
that they were palindromes which are
much less common in Russian than in
English and it wasn't that hard to
translate once I realized they were
pallant once i was told they were
palindromes and actually in english it's
much more obvious that they're
palindromes to me I think Russian style
palindromes are different
so I had some really very basic
questions it's it's I really could not
have done this absolutely could not have
done it just by asking native other
native speakers I really needed the
author in this case there are actually
footnotes in this book and someone some
review actually took us to task because
in the section where their interpreters
are where there's the interviews with
the refugees which takes up a lot
especially in the first part of the book
and the story of the interpreter as in
his job there's a lot of the German
conversations are translated into
Russian now some of this is like Al feet
are saying I mean it's not complicated
anything and the point is not that you
don't understand the German the point is
that it's translated and someone said
why did you translate that German you
know we couldn't you know it was clear
what it was and I thought this person
really didn't get it you know that's not
the point to understand what they say
the point is that it's the translation
there at the bottom of the page so there
are actually are footnotes but they're
part of the original text thank you so
much both of you can you can you speak a
little bit mr. she's keen about how long
you were an interpreter and just a
little bit about that experience and and
what you're writing hours were since you
must have been translating a good bit
our teachers miss me you see the novel
when it comes it doesn't ask me do I
have time to write or not yeah just I
must write and yeah you have always
nights you have always I don't know
saturdays sundays mornings evenings I
don't understand the question most of
what I wanted wanted to know was about
how long you you worked as an
interpreter and besides the stories the
plunging into the stories or hearing the
stories that you got what that
experience or how that experience fed
into the the novel yeah directly
absolutely the experience indirectly no
you come and you write down the stories
yeah and severe very unpleasant actually
situation because you as a human being
you don't want to have the stories
inside you and in Russia which is the
source of all horrible stories yeah you
can avoid this just by not watching TV
not reading newspapers yeah just sitting
at home closing windows and here the
situation was this person telling the
story was sitting in front of you and
you have no possibility to avoid you
take it into a cell and then you have
these stories and you bring them home
and they are already in your notebook
and then they are part of the novel
because for me I can't event I'm not
professional writer I can't even things
i just write what i experienced and for
me it was just the part of the novel and
my work was actually not to create but
to cut i would compare working on this
novel just with the work of some
sculptor sculpture like it has a big
block of miramar and just marmar marble
and what doesn't belong to the figure
must get the way and so I have my life
with all the stories with all my people
yeah I 11 people I hate and I must just
cut off what doesn't belong to the novel
and if I cut everything but doesn't
belong then I have my novel how it works
but they're not profession because the
professional writer must write one book
a year or one book in two years in three
years maximum yeah and I write my book
only one book in five or six years it's
not professional at all
no no no Telstra was not professional we
who are not professionals they'll stand
me we are not professionals now the best
fighter is the writer who's alive
because so many times I wanted to ask
homework something he's not available
but you chose to read the epigraph today
so i take it that it says something very
important about this process so you
talked about the stories you heard as an
interpreter and the letters of your
mother or the diary of your mother which
you didn't preserve but yuri invented is
the life of somebody else and i was
wondering this distinction any person
today in the digits yuri tosto disick
rania the real mini what did you
what did you return that wasn't yours
and what did you reveal that you have
preserved
anything is too personal question good
question it's a good question no
actually the same question is what is
writing about yeah why do people right
it's the same question for me it is the
possibility to understand something very
important to ask questions maybe which
are without answers at all but it
belongs to the Russian tradition the
Russian literary tradition is very
important for me and this tradition
means not to entertain a Russian writer
never did never depend on reader and in
the normal situations you depend on
reader yeah the mower book books use
cell the battery and in Russia before
the Revolution and after the Revolution
the most popular books were forbidden it
was impossible to buy them or to sell
them this is the Russian tradition for
me writing not for selling but just for
for some other reason like reading is in
Russia absolute different thing like
just reading here here in the normal
situation I mean you read for your
education for your entertainment to kill
the time and so on a lot of situation
where you need reading but in Russia
when I was 15 16 yeah I was in the
situation where everything every part of
the life every conversation every
dialogue ever is humiliating because i
was born in the land of slaves in the
country of slaves and i was asleep
and the reading was the only situation
which was not humiliating me but
established the situation of my personal
human dignity and my body belong to the
state the only territory of freedom was
what was in my head and I was fighting
for this territory of my personal
freedom by region and so exactly the
writing was also much more important as
people wrote books and write books in
Russia not just thinking of selling but
thinking of answering some important
questions and I compared writing and
reading in Russia with blood transfusion
rock by writing I want to share with
somebody with ya with my reader what
gives me my life yeah what gives life to
me I share with him and reader gets what
he needs for his life from me but the
group of the blood the blood group must
match yeah if it doesn't match it could
kill region could kill it was killing me
when I was at school and we had to read
some Soviet writers it was killing me we
had to write essays on the books of the
great Russian writer Lana tillage
Brezhnev Molly's in la vostra Janie we
had to write essays it was killing me
yeah so and actually I'm answering the
same question in all my books this
question came to me so in my case it was
maybe I was five or six
was on the vacation summer vacation
entire summer house in New Zealand near
Moscow I was with my grandma and we went
shot to the railway station for shopping
and tone our cool it's very actual the
actual street there there was a dead cat
and tall people passed by and she
returned she came back took the shovel
and buried this cat and for me it was
the first shock of this life will my
grandma died like this cat below people
I love my mom my brother died as a skirt
will I be like this cat what to do with
death and then I just try to answer this
question but if you are 16 and if you
are 5050 you have the same question but
you have different answers so that is
why I still write my novels because I
get some different answers to the same
question
first of all thank you both um second
well so mr. Sheen you mentioned that you
felt bad you woke up in a panic one day
wondering if you were perhaps doing
something dishonest to Isabella azhagiya
Isabella yo d'ivoire Isabella you diva
but she was dead and you were creating
that story as much as you could to the
people who you were translating for they
were still alive and you were taking
their stories and coming home did you
ever have the same feelings of I wonder
if what I'm doing is okay to these
people who were still alive and who
could actually confront you no you see I
writing about Isabella urea was writing
about Isabella you river and writing
about my people so I just took some some
stories I actually the stories didn't
belong to these people because most of
them were invented because people who
come to ask for political asylum and you
can see it once who are these people the
Swiss official can't see do you see and
most of them were just failed
businessman and in Russia if you can't
pay your debt back you will be shot yeah
and people just we're trying to save
their lives their families but when they
came to Switzerland they couldn't tell
the truth the truth is they are in
danger this is the truth but the storage
they had to invent they had to be
political as persecuted and so they told
the story that they are Jews and the
Russian nationalists beat their children
and so on and Sonja and actually all the
stories you will never be sure what is
invented what is
not invented here and the task or the
Swiss officer was just to find some
details which are not true and that was
enough just to say no it's very
difficult problem that's political
asylum it's a very difficult problem
because people are coming really and
they are in danger and as a good
Christian yeah you must help all people
who are draw about to drown in water and
you stay here on the show and you could
brush it team at espace action from its
throat and the life life preserver yeah
but at first but we are in some law
state so at first you have to ask these
drowning people I owe political are not
political yeah what should they say of
course they would anybody was to save
their family would lie I'm sure anybody
because if you want to save your
children you will do anything but in
reality the even the told story doesn't
matter because the law state has just
the Switzerland for example has just
some quote quotable quote just so many
cases yeah could be positive and not
more it's very difficult situation with
you so there are some questions which
have no answer and there are some
problems which could not be solved but
we must still think of it what was the
question I actually forgot ah yeah did I
have the same feeling with these people
know I did some of them were so
unpleasant some of them were so
unpleasant really yeah and what really
bothered me what really bothered me
you can translate the same sentence the
same sentence in two absolutely
different ways it will be the right
correction but one way of the
translation will be for this person the
second way will be against this person
and I discovered that when the person is
sympathetic and translating for him if
the person is not sympathetic I'm
translating against them that was the
problem that was the problem yeah
because you shouldn't do this
I'd like to go back to your to your
reading you were talking about how
school round literature for you Brezhnev
and so on but I remember reading in an
interview we talked about I think your
older brother had some books one was
such a circle loaf I believe how did
that change your attitude toward reading
what was it particularly about Sasha
Sokoloff who happens to be one of my
favorite authors what was particular
about sarthak oh I was 17 and this book
has been published in America and after
one you are during one year it came the
book they're not copy not the book came
to Moscow and I got it in my hands does
a miracle yeah and the second miracle
was that first time in my life I
realized that not only gods of the past
lie like Tolstoy like unprofessional
Tolstoy and asterisk and so on could
really make miracles but people living
now are also gods yeah because they
would make miracles out of words and I
was so much impressed by that book
called lead rakov that some years I was
just it was in my heart yeah and it I
spent a lot of years just trying to get
rid of circle often in my heart and in
my mind I think I managed yeah and
actually for me he was the top the top
of Russian literature but not with his
latest book and after I discovered for
myself another Russian genius alexander
gulch team so for me now the top of
russian literature is Alexander
goldstein I suppose some people here
know Alexander gardenia so I'm happy
than to bring good news for you
it's a Russian Jew he went to Israel and
the late seventies and he lived in
Israel writing in Russian after
perestroika he was published in Moscow
by very good publishing house can alone
oval it's returnable Enya and he died
maybe four years ago as a writer must
die so he wrote his novel to last note
to the end and that he was very ill with
cancer and I'm sure in 15 years here in
at Columbia University and other
American universities all professors
will consider our time now our epic as
the epic of Alexander Gulch teen and we
other writers will be just the
contemporary are oval examiner question
we'll just shared with him the epic and
he wrote wonderful novels bonilla
famagusta spa koyna Paulo and if you ask
me what Russian writers are important
and genius nowadays i would say read
alexander gud stain Brandon
thank you great opportunity and also I
really liked the format
I really liked the format because I
think it sort of previews the book and
add something to it for those of us who
have already read this sort of
translation and the back and forth is a
lot of what the book is about but I
wanted to ask a question actually 14 for
each of you McKay offer for you I would
like to ask about the there's there's a
lot of maps and mapmakers throughout
your works there's the interpreter son
in union and volus draws maps for him
and he spends a lot of time sort of
describing the maps to the reader and
pinning the maps on the wall there's
also a map of where all the refugees
come from and then in Sassy's may Allah
one of the characters is a cartographer
there's another a quote that I have seen
of yours is that your novels take place
v's do you see that I've always in
everywhere I think I understand more or
less the always factor but I'd like to
ask you about the space and whether that
is connected with the the map makers and
the maps that are prevalent in the books
and then Marian you said that you've
been you've been working with Mikael's
work sense since calligraphy lesson
which is his very first story and this
is his third book I was wondering why
you chose this book what grabbed your
attention about this book is it its
marketability or is it sent something
else that they grabbed your attention
thank you
it's easier to us Oh mind-seizer dancer
in fact I was asked to translate this
probably because I had already
translated the other two pieces actually
I have no idea why they asked me I'm
very glad they did it was not my idea
and I found in my career as a translator
that I get to suggest very little mostly
I'm just asked thank you very much for
this question about the maps so no idea
to buy by chance just the maps I don't
know why maps just they have to be there
this place yeah and what about the space
it's the main thing actually where does
this in late yeah where is the sin lado
of the novel and I always try to find
the real place real space where
everything is happening in rug when we
take on my nose for example the
calligraphy lesson the space of this
short story is actually a rational
literary consciousness and everything
what happens there is happening always
and forever the taking of Ismael starts
in the Russian literature and ends
actually with the birth of my son in
Switzerland and veneer in Wallace is
really everywhere in Russia in
Switzerland but it is not but the main
task is to overcome the real geography
the Unreal geography
to put my characters into the real space
real geography I compare it with it's
much easier to speak about the time
actually uh actually it is the same time
and space it's the same yet for me the
task of the literature is to take what
is important out from this unreal time
to the real time from the Unreal space
into the real space the space and the
time we share I call it it's time and
space for the journalists because
everything what happens disappears
absolutely at once and they think it
will not disappear if they put it into
the newspaper today but tomorrow it is
the newspaper of yesterday it is the
symbol of death and the art the artist
writer can take the most important
things for this unreal reality which
disappears every second and to put it to
take it with him into the real time into
the real space where everything that
takes place always and there is where is
no death that's the sense of their not
add something to this there's also one
location you've left out which is Rome
and as far as as far as the abstract
eternal I mean it's the Eternal City and
and the constant returned to Italy and
to Rome I think it's part of the this
aspect of universality and of kind of an
abstract everywhere yes yeah it could be
a Roman could be Russia it could be in
Europe it doesn't matter but it is not
they're wrong which disappears every
second it is than their own which will
stay forever
and what I wanted to add yeah it's about
the title so nobody asked about the
title the title means so it's clear for
every everyone what the title is and
actually the title is not made in here
yeah but in Russian veneer and Wallace
and Vigneron Wallace it is a plant at
the anthem Capella's vinieras and in all
languages it is the same in Russian
vinieron Wallace the French translation
is entitled sugar Devin news the Italian
title is Calvin area and only in English
it is made in Harry are not Venus here
and in the book no it is a plant in this
room yeah on the ruins everywhere and in
Russia it is a house plant which will
die in winter without the human warmth
and this is actually the symbol of this
book there is in this book as in our
life a lot of cruelty and violence but
it is a book about the overcoming of the
scroll to economic violence the only way
to overcome it is through the human
warmth what is the book about thank you
very much